I want to solve the problem
[Music]
just yesterday the world's first smart
gun hit the market can you shoot it with
your phone like not like that what's
smart that's cool as well you open it
with your like giraffe yeah it's 1500
bucks and uh it will unlock with facial
recognition
but what if you got Colvin he got the
mask on or fingerprint or fingerprint
okay okay yeah either way I don't like
anything like that like your laptop will
unlock in less than a second and it will
lock up again immediately after use I
don't like that you don't like it why
how come well so like you know what the
whole like uh conversation of like
digital versus like analog stuff like if
you've ever used anything in digital you
know there's times where things [__] up
and there's a lack a glitch right the
glitch even when it comes to a car
sometimes you go like that and then it
turns on like a second later when you
need a gun you don't have time for that
[__] it needs to be right then and there
so it has the gun needs to stay analog
in my opinion you know I asked the same
question my my cousin who works for the
Air Force and he like and I always asked
him like why does everything still look
old school like in the 80s it has knobs
like why don't we do like iPads and come
on because he says when you're up in
space
you don't want anything to glitch yep
they'd rather have it mechanical like
I'll take this out roll down the window
in space and fix it tune it up and then
put it back in you want to manually fit
something yeah
mechanical yeah so they don't want
anything with computers like they don't
trust them that makes sense that makes
sense that does make sense and I shut
the [__] up out here
at that but when it comes to guns you
know which one I do like but I saw the
one that you have by your bed it's like
a little contract like a safe like a
case yeah yeah and you put your hand in
and it reads your like it reads your
thumb and then you're able to get your
gun back I have that next to my bedside
I thought that was pretty cool that
makes sense like if somebody's coming in
because I want it right next to it I
don't have to go look for it in the I
got one where you put your hand in it
goes boom and if the door opens and you
can grab your gun that's tight so I have
I have you have one of those or
it's like it's like they read like to
your fingerprints you and they just put
your hand on it and then as soon as you
put your hand on it the door opens and
then you can grab it bam I like that I
like that that but then it has two
options it has the fingerprint and then
it has a numerical I still go with the
numerical just because that's still more
analog than in case you only got one
side or whatever I'd rather just go boom
boom but you lose seconds when you go
I'm about time they get to the room Bros
it's more reliable yeah than a
fingerprint beep yeah I don't know about
those
Nickelodeon yeah yeah everything's
Nickelodeon women
yeah I don't know about the key though I
don't know about because someone could
just steal this one one reason because
the [__] key dude I don't want to
[__] wake up and just be like oh dude
don't make me do keys
who the [__] guys running in the room
one of the things they like about this
is that
um like they're kind of thinking about
mass shooting and they're like oh if
somebody steals a gun or grabs their
parents gun or something they wouldn't
be able to use it no no I get what
they're doing they're always solving
problems without looking at the problem
oh here we go you look at the last time
no the last couple of like mass
shootings did they borrow someone else's
gun did they find a gun living you know
what I mean like I'm all for decreasing
matchings obviously and I'm actually
even foreign
I'm even for more gun control like make
it harder to get guns but if you pass it
get whatever the [__] you want right so
like
I'm but you're talking witchcraft son
but I want a song
yeah yeah yeah it's never been people
finding random [__] guns all over the
house and they take it some people are
gonna be pissed I want my son Bill to
get a gun
[Laughter]
they're not the people that are games go
bang when people are getting guns from
the black market they're not they're
getting like uh scratched out serial
numbers they're getting bad like you
know bad guns anyways so this will not
even make it into the black it's like
it's like a undercover guy hey start
circulating these in the black market
what the [__] face ID hell no yeah yeah
so now so they're not solving the
problem wasn't there like a press
conference with this one Sergeant or
police chief and then the a reporter was
like oh would that have happened with
more gun control and he was like
you can change the law but criminals
break the law they're like [__] yeah
they're like no way wait a minute what
are you talking about what now you can
make the Law whatever you want like
they're they're breaking all of the laws
because the law is already you can't
kill anybody yeah exactly yeah
he has nothing to do with guns you just
can't even kill him I think people
mostly they just
idea of like but you
Z for them to like break the law
I've heard that a lot it's like they're
always like yeah but they're just the
culture the gun culture makes it so easy
there was a way bigger gun culture
previously meaning like you could get
mail order guns you could get it was
easier to get but there wasn't mass
shootings at the level we're seeing
today well it was much easier to get
guns but why is it much harder to get
guns I just don't think but there's more
mass shootings yeah there wasn't as soon
as I'm hard to get a gun depends what
state you're in it comes on what you
consider well it's nearly impossible to
get uh I think it's like permit to carry
right well my thing is why don't we all
just carry bro that's the case that's
what I'm saying right then all right
then
let me tell you something about Arizona
God damn it when I was growing up in
Arizona I love Arizona I mean I love it
too brother go kiss your lips right now
let me tell you something about Arizona
dude Arizona like I feel like here's the
thing about California and Arizona when
it comes to my guns right it's like the
opposite over here people get a little
Lippy people get a little like you know
Brave like we saw the wall out they're
more crazy to talk all this [__] and
Arizona they're very careful because
they know he's caring yeah everyone so
they're thinking twice about getting
crazy like there's not to be a lot of
people getting crazy like I've seen a
lot of people getting people's places in
Arizona it's like if they don't like
each other they just look at each other
it's like all right what you want to do
this and they're like I'm walk away if
you walk I'm gonna walk away all right
yes because they know everyone's
carrying something and you know how I
know it's [__] right there dude the
piece is right there yeah I remember
going to a Walmart there and I was like
there's a lot of cowboys here yeah so a
lot of people think twice about getting
a little crazy holsters open holsters
the guy that got that shot a politician
there right he uh shot I think gab
Gabriel something uh he shot her
they [__] got that [__]
seconds because everybody in there had
guns so everyone turned around and shot
him
I heard you wanted to get the crowd
throwing down and had their guns already
on his [__] head oh [__] so you know
what I'm saying like that to me is like
Yo's like it's we're pretty much taking
care of ourselves though the heroes
because this is like everybody like if
somebody tries to trip over there it's
like bro everybody's caring yeah so it's
like I don't know I would think can't
start some [__] you know so what if we
all do what if we all care that's such
an Arizona mentality but you know I'm
just saying like I'll feel a lot more
comfortable if it's like if I'm at a
movie theater and I got my piece and
some [__] kid with this backpack Zips
it up I'm like I hope there's Cheetos on
that [__] bag some [__] and then
he's just like I just wanted to get into
horses all right like let me see it let
me see that My Philosophy you lay a
[__] you know I mean you you
check a [__] especially nowadays
with all the school shooting or Mall
shootings or Bank shootings you hear
this everywhere I don't know I just feel
like I feel like California if you armed
the citizens of California as they stand
right I don't know what to do I think a
lot of them would be just [__] nuts I
think everyone needs some sort of
Education stuff yeah I think California
that's important I do it I don't like
that I do like the fact that you should
go to some type of training and then you
get a certain yeah or just one
certificates all right you you know how
to handle it you know how to take it off
like you know because you got to go to
Driver's school right before you take a
driver's test just like something like I
think I think that put in 50 hours I
really do yeah I think they show you how
to you know the education education
where did that go back to the laws then
if they make the law that you got to do
the education thing and then is that
what people are talking about I don't
know makes it harder wow well no it's
just like this is not here you can't
conceal carry it's like next impossible
yeah yeah but what I'm saying is when
you can't get a gun and making it harder
it doesn't is that where the law comes
in you have to make it harder to get a
gun you know what dude it's [__]
simple that ticket really is [__]
simple it's [__] simple you pass a
test you show that you're [__] smart
enough to carry a gun and you give him
the gun period yeah it's that [__]
simple I'm not gonna give it to a
[__] idiot it's like for a while
though [__] is there any way they can
prevent that guy from selling it to an
idiot no yeah no dude California the the
test is 50. the test is like 80 like
it's 480 approved if you fail it if
you're dumb
are you serious yeah like one of them
would be like Steven Avery dude let's
make it a little hard at least dude
yeah to me I think that that's simple
it's just like
this guy's smart enough he passed this
test okay cool but the crazy thing is
after you pass it and you buy a gun you
don't have to like show that you still
have it every year oh so like if I sold
it to an idiot who couldn't get a gun
how do I how do you prevent me from
doing in California that guy has to take
a test before he can transfer to him
but technically the right way to do it
is you have to meet at a gun store
transfer it now the guns under their
name and the gun sits at the gun store
for 21 days um if I were to sell you a
gun yeah we go to a gun store if we do
it the right way the gun sits there for
21 days and then you pick it up but do
you think there's a way like you know
how this mechanism kind of solves that
how like now you can't just let some
other guy use it is there a mechanism
like this
that's maybe not this but it keeps
someone who can't have a gun from
getting one from someone who can cut off
their hands
[Laughter]
Aladdin style and going
to know if uh people so if you're not a
criminal you're actually not
incentivized to do like not go to the
store because if I sell you a gun then
you go kill someone I'm in trouble oh
okay because it's your gun so I'm bet
I'm highly incentivized to go to a store
and change just like a pink slip right
like I don't want an Embark right right
kill someone knocks on me you're talking
about
right
now I ain't gonna [__] but for nobody
I'll be I don't know dude I am a little
too don't have a gun though
[Music]